[Music]
in the sundrenched garden of down house
insects Buzz a low Symphony as they dip
methodically from Bloom to
bloom the stems of wild flowers wave
gently in the warm breeze and a barn cat
stalks the fat pigeons that amble
gracelessly Across The
Lawns it is an idilic scene
but one that goes unnoticed by the
usually attentive occupant of the stone
country
house because Charles Darwin is in
mental
Agony instead of his usual calm
contemplative walks around the dappled
perimeter of the estate
grounds he now irritably Paces the
creaking floorboards in his darken
study the shutters are drawn against the
summer
sunlight all the better to focus a
tormented over tired
mind but it is no
use no amount of pacing will solve
Darwin's problem he mutters under his
breath and storms towards his desk
sweeping aside the crumpled papers he
dips his pen and scratches out a final
line
the case at present must remain
inexplicable and may be truly urged as a
valid argument against My Views here
entertained the year is
1859 and Darwin is rushing to complete
the manuscript for his book On the
Origin of
Species
for the last 25 years since his time as
a naturalist aboard the HMS Beagle The
Scholar has been consumed with the
connections between living
things everywhere he looks he sees inter
relationships between animals plants and
the non-living
World which are fundamental in shaping
the way individuals look and behave
fundamental in fact to the way they came
about to their
[Music]
evolution for two decades he has worked
and reworked his theories but ultimately
he is
prevaricating he's not the kind of man
to rush and publish a provocative
idea he wants every loose end to tide up
every every problem to have a solution
and every possible argument a
repost but now his hand has been forced
another young naturalist Alfred Russell
Wallace has also drawn the same
conclusions about the evolution of
living things and has already published
his preliminary
ideas Darwin must consolidate his
theories and get them to print or else
Decades of quiet contemplation would
have been for
not and that means he must publish
before finding a solution to one of his
biggest
conundrums the origin of animal
life Darwin's theory of evolution by
natural selection describes how new
species come about as a result of
variation and competition within living
populations new characteristics are
acquired gradually and Amplified by
continued pressure from the living and
non-living
environment over centuries the beaks of
finches can transform to suit the
available food sources on different
Galapagos
Islands over Millennia Giant glyptodon
now extinct transform into their smaller
cousins the
armadillos all through the living world
and the fossil record Darwin sees
evidence of gradual change and with
enough time those changes can accumulate
to produce the complex and diverse
animal forms that populate the world
today but time is not on Darwin's
side
not just in this new pressure to publish
but in undertaking the origin of these
complex animals in the first
place according to his theories animal
life should take a long time to arise
gradually developing from simpler forms
acquiring unique characteristics peac
mail but the fossil record tells a very
different story
it shows none of those simple animals
know gradual
transition instead the first animal
fossils make a sudden explosive entrance
into the fossil
record without warning or
Preamble tracing the layers of rocks
back through time one moment animal
fossils are there and the next they're
[Music]
not it is as if they and all animal life
appear miraculously and
instantaneously from nowhere at
[Music]
all it's a serious blow to Darwin's
otherwise well- eviden theory of gradual
transformation and Darwin being the
cautious and anxious man that he is has
lost countless nights of sleep over this
nrum but there's no solution among his
notes among the fossils scattered around
the study floor or in the sun soaked
Garden beyond the
shutters as he wrote in the now finished
manuscript the case must indeed remain
inexplicable at least for the time
being
[Music]
now however we are more than 150 years
on from those tortured moments with a
wealth of paleontological Discovery and
evolutionary theory under our
belts if there is a solution to Darwin's
Dilemma it must surely lie among all
that accumulated
[Music]
knowledge now we are finally equipped
with the tools to understand the sudden
appearance of animal life in the
earliest rocks of the
furoic was Darwin wrong or the evidence
merely
incomplete what really caused the
Cambrian
[Music]
explosion
this episode of history of the earth is
brought to you by better help the online
therapy service used by over 4 million
people
worldwide like Darwin in his mental
anguish at contemplating the origins of
life on Earth is something interfering
with your happiness or preventing you
from achieving your
goals starting therapy can be hard the
right therapist for you might not live
in your area and the face to interaction
of therapy can be
uncomfortable better help connects you
with a credential therapist who is
trained to listen and give you helpful
unbiased
advice all you have to do is fill out a
questionnaire and in most cases you'll
be matched with a therapist within 48
hours if the therapist you first match
with doesn't feel like the right fit you
can easily switch to a new therapist at
no additional cost all you have to do is
fill out a questionnaire and in most
cases you'll be matched with a therapist
within for 48 hours if the therapist
you're first matched with doesn't feel
like the right fit you can easily switch
to a new therapist at no additional
cost most importantly you can schedule
therapy sessions for times that're
convenient for you in whichever format
you prefer be it via phone call as a
video chat or even via messaging if
that's what you
prefer as Darwin knew all too well our
brains are the most important of all
organs so why not give our minds the
proper care and detention they require
if you think you might benefit from
therapy consider better help clicking
our Link in the description below will
give you 10% off your first month and
help to support the
channel thanks to better help for
supporting educational content on
YouTube when Maryweather Lewis and
William Clark embarked marked on their
epic voyage across America and back in
the early
1800s they had little idea of what to
expect from that wild Uncharted
country their president had tasked them
with the mission to not only seek a
possible River route to the Pacific
Ocean but also to observe and document
the animals they discovered along the
way the promise of unexplored Revenue
has always been a great motivator for
scientific inquiry and Lewis took crash
courses in botony and zoology to give
him a head start in what was already
known and what was
not but the party were explorers first
and foremost and their approaches to
Zoological study was often as wild as
the country they
[Music]
charted in September 1804 somewhere
between the naaba River in Nebraska and
the Tieton River in South
Dakota they came across a hillside
pockmarked all over with
holes in the quiet before their approach
these holes were guarded by what the
Explorers described as a village of
small
[Music]
animals who barked a warning before
disappearing inside the
Burrows never once to miss an
opportunity to fulfill their scientific
brief Lu and Clark endeavored to catch
one of these furry Critters and first
tried digging down into the Burrows
after
them but even after reaching a depth of
6 ft they were empty-handed and changed
tack only by pouring buckets and buckets
of water into the animals holes did they
finally manage to flush one out trap it
and send it home for
study the party offered many possible
names for this new elusive animal such
as Barking Squirrel ground rats or
burrow
squirrels but the name that eventually
stuck is still one we Ed
today prairie
dogs in just two weeks while trekking
the 100 or so miles between these two
rivers of the American Plains the party
encountered three more animals new to
them the jack rabbit the coyote and the
HGH
horn and by the end of their 2-year
Expedition the pair had documented some
122 Great American animals for the first
[Music]
time animals which it should be said
were already well known to the native
tribes of these regions but were
nevertheless a source of endless Wonder
inquiry and inevitably Revenue to the
settlers
today the Curious zoologist need not
chart the unknown to discover the
diversity of animal life that our planet
has to
offer a simple stroll along a rocky
Shoreline anywhere on Earth will
[Music]
suffice there sandwiched between
towering Cliffs that March to the very
end of the
landscape and the gray blue expanse of
the open
ocean the deceptively calm Waters of
rock pools and Sandbar ponds are in fact
teeming with animal
[Music]
life there are sponges members of the
film
periphera despite looking a little like
a melted version of a bathroom sponge
these lumpy porous encrustations on the
rocks are the amorphous skeletons of
simple
animals they make their living by
filtering the sea water through tiny
pores extracting bacteria and other food
particles to feed their simple rooted
bodies there are the soft jellylike
tubic of sea
anemones above the water line they sulk
folded in on themselves like resentful
puls in Hues of angry mauve and mossy
green but when they find themselves
submerged they unfurl blooming into
graceful many tentacled flowered
polyps but each of these tentacles
swaying gracefully in the current Bears
Fierce stinging cells that shoot painful
paralyzing poison at the slightest
[Music]
touch they are
narian a group of animals defined by
their stinging Armory deployed to help
them immobilize and catch their
food many jellyfish as well as
hard-bodied corals whose skeletons break
down to golden sand and narian
too there are arthropods so named for
their pairs of jointed
appendages they include the six-legged
insects that flit around in the salty
air as well as 10 limed crustations like
crabs that Sidle out from Rocky Hollows
to peer back at their observers with
alien stalked
eyes with their hardened exoskeletons
the arthropods are the largest group of
invertebrate animals accounting for over
80% of all known animal
species there are mollusks another
diverse group whose rockpool
Representatives might include the sea
snails with their striped coiled shells
or the pointed limpets that cling to the
rocks with an iron grip that only
tightens further the moment the creature
is
Disturbed muscles welks cockal and
oysters offer a mkan smus board of
edible life too of identified by the
protective shells it is nevertheless the
fleshy mantle within that truly defines
a
mollusk small frilled sea slugs might
dazzle with a flamboyant flash of color
as they drift aimlessly in the
water
while resting octopuses skulk in the
shadows pulsing color and texture across
their skin as they dream of the Open
Water mindless and blisteringly
intelligent they are about as different
as two animals can be and yet both are
mollusks then there are the spiny punks
of the rock pool the
kerms sea urchins hide in plain sight
the broken outline of their dark bristle
shells blending into the dappled light
to become the ultimate spiny Hazard to
unsuspecting
waiters they move slowly Defying Gravity
across Rock and Sand powered by hundreds
of tiny hydraulic tube feet projecting
from the underside of their
shells great ing surfaces free of algae
with a five beaked mouth suspended in
their
[Music]
undercarriage they are a pasti of the
finest Fantastical fiction and yet few
who find their discarded heart-shaped
shells orever aware of how truly odd
they
are the kerms are unique in possessing a
five fold symmetry something which is
flaunted by the five prongs of most
starfish they too possess the bizarre
fleshy tube feet and terrifying beaked
Moore but dress up their alienness with
a dazzling show of
[Music]
geometry and there are
worms so many different
kinds
[Music]
one 20th century biologist John hallan
once joked that if God created the
animals then he must have had an
inordinate fondness for
beetles but considering the major groups
of life that surely must be a fondness
for
worms there are anelids the spiny rag
worms that lurk in dark Rocky crevices
or the lug worms that leave coiled sand
pil on the freshly wetted tidal
[Music]
flat they in the merians better known as
ribbon
worms one such ribbon known as the
bootlace worm may look little more than
a pile of discarded intestines but
claims the title of the world's longest
animal had up to 55 M
long and there are flat worms who make a
parasitic living on other fleshy
creatures and if this were not enough
not every animal is visible to the naked
eye there are also countless other
microscopic forms each a perfect animal
less than a fraction of a millimeter in
size there are Brians who live alongside
the sponges in encrusted colonies they
are not one animal but many inhabiting a
densely packed Metropolis of their own
[Music]
making they eight-legged snub-nosed
tardigrades cloring their way through
fibrous seaweed in search of their next
meal there are rotifers with their buzo
likee mouths brushing particles into
their guts as they stretch and pucker
themselves through the
water
and there are nematode worms also known
as round worms which are found
everywhere these are the most
extensively parasitic animals on Earth
and it's been said that if all other
life on our planet suddenly vanished we
would still see a shadow of it written
in the nematodes Left
[Music]
Behind of course the zoologist thems is
a part of this animal diversity
too as they Crouch to observe the
swarming rockpool
life they like all humans are a
cordate a
vertebrate a group which encompasses all
mammals fish reptiles amphibians and
birds these large carismatic organisms
which we doubtless consider first when
we think about animal life on Earth
whether it be whales dinosaurs ostriches
and
monkeys they are all Cates
[Music]
too Cates may be unique in hogging the
Limelight and in sparking a branch that
can ultimately come to consider
themselves but in reality they are no
more preeminent or diverse than their
mosan or vermicular
cousins
all this diversity and disparity
existing within such a small pocket of
earth's surface is remarkable in
itself but what is perhaps more
remarkable is the fact that almost all
of these animal fer all of this
incredible
variety appeared on Earth in a
geological blink of the
[Music]
eye
after almost 4 billion years of slow
progress in which life remained
microscopic out of sight and out of the
visible fossil record
538.org today appeared in the Cambrian
oceans and not just that there were
other animal groups types of arthropods
and sponges that swarmed those ancient
[Music]
seas and which are now
extinct this was not The Stumbling
experimentation of quilted flesh that
defined the ediacaran period but a
resounding and definitive breakthrough
in animal
[Music]
ecology zoologists who found themselves
within the mid Cambrian ocean perhaps
510 million years ago would find a
diverse and interconnected ecosystem to
rival that of any modern rock
[Music]
[Laughter]
pool there are sponges hulking formless
across the ocean floor filtering
microscopic food particles from the
murky
Waters there are rudimentary narian
lurking inside rough cup-shaped
skeletons as a precursor to The Reef
building corals of later
times there are worms that wri across
the seafloor leaving crisscrossing
trails behind
them While others for the first time
burrow down into the soft muds
disrupting the delicate sedimentary
layers and churning organic Rich
material up into the water
[Music]
above and there are plenty of animals
that take advantage of that
material like deposit and filter feeding
arthopods and mollusks of multifarious
Form and
[Music]
Function sweeping the water clear of
every spec of primary
[Music]
nutrition meanwhile Sinister Shadows
cast from above reveal the presence of
predatory animals
too who for the first time make a living
preing upon their own taxonomic
[Music]
kin plus wherever life thrives there is
also
death and some new animals choose a
scavenger's way of
life feasting on the remains of others
before bacteria move in to complete the
[Music]
Decay and there are parasites just as
there are
today choosing to leech their life force
from the hard work of others
[Music]
it is the kind of community that will
come to exist in habitats all over the
world throughout the
furoic although the particular denisons
of the cambon are often more bizarre and
extravagant than any we might see
later a testament perhaps to this golden
age of
invention and
experimentation there is
henia which walks on fleshy tubular legs
while sporting a terrifying Mohawk of
spines along its
[Music]
back there is the Canadia worm
flamboyant with iridescent Frills all
along its diminutive
body there was armored with waxier
covered in scaly plates and spines as
protection from the looming Predators
above and among these Predators there is
a Nal acarus which undulates through the
open ocean probing for food with two
elongated prong likee appendages next to
its disc-shaped
[Music]
mouth and there is opabinia equally
terrifying with its five eyes and hose
like proboscis that ends in a spined
claw perfect for dealing Unexpected
death from
[Music]
above much of this Cambrian diversity
would have been unknown to Darwin as he
racked and red over the origins of
animal
life 19th century paleontologists
certainly knew of the most successful
Cambrian organisms like trilobites and
brachiopods but this wondrous ecology
has only been revealed with discoveries
made in the last 150
years and yet this modern
paleontological treasure has done little
to address Darwin's
Dilemma
tracing back the Cambrian fossil record
to its ultimate
beginning the larger more complex forms
may become more scarce but there are
still animal traces to be
found the rocks at the very base of the
Cambrian belonging to the fortunian
period are filled with the fragmented
shells of enigmatic wormlike or mollusk
like
[Music]
animals
these so-called small Shelly fossils are
like the diminutive drum roll to the
animal Symphony that was to
come and yet they too seem to appear
without warning or
Preamble they may have been the
precursors to the Staggering diversity
of later
times but what were their precursors
what really happened at the beginning of
the Cambrian to Russia so many fossils
first small and Shelly then numerous and
complex into
[Music]
being in August
1968 the city of Prague in then
czechslovakia was filled with an
uncharacteristically scholarly crowd
[Music]
the city which was enjoying a brief
moment of calm amidst a drawn out
political Uprising had been selected as
the host for the 23rd International
geological
Congress a chance for geoscientists from
across the world to come together and
present discuss and debate the latest
scientific breakthroughs pertaining to
our planet
and this Congress promised to be a
spectacular one with 3,000 scientists
attending from 91 countries and more
than 700 pieces of new research on the
Slate it was the largest such meeting in
almost a 100
years a show of unprecedented collabor
aberation at an otherwise tense time for
the
world one of the highlights of the
five-week long agenda was an in-depth
investigation of the Cambrian
explosion the best geoscientists in the
world would come together to discuss
what had been learned in the 110 years
since Darwin's
Dilemma to define the exact date at
which animal life exploded and to
consider how it could have come
[Music]
about but it was not to
be on the evening of the 20th of August
at the end of the congress's very first
day Soviet tanks rolled into the streets
of Prague under the cover of
Darkness
by morning the invading Communists had
seized control of all the major
transport and power centers in the
country resting power from the
revolutionaries and putting a definitive
end to the liberalization that the Cs
had been fighting for for
months in that single night the hopes of
the country and of the assembled
geoscientists evaporated Into Thin Air
[Music]
the Congress was
cancelled scientists fled home with the
optimism of just a few days earlier now
cast under a dark
cloud much of the research and
discussion was postponed until the next
Congress all later since ever new topics
arose to steal the
Limelight
in the end it would be another 15 years
before the subject of the Cambrian
explosion was
Revisited to discuss what had been
learned in the 20 years
since evidence points to a sudden
explosion of animal life around 540
million years ago but the best
scientists think twice before taking
anything at face
value before considering the very
difficult question of how diverse and
complex animal life could appear
seemingly out of thin air they first
entertain the idea that there is
something missing some part of the
puzzle which would explain what we're
seeing without invoking miraculous acts
of
creation something that would suggest
that the Cambrian explosion is not truly
an explosion of animal life but rather
an explosion of
[Music]
evidence in the middle of the 19th
century Scottish geologist Charles Lyle
was the first to suggest that
paleontologists of the time were perhaps
not as omniscient as they would like to
believe and that the fossil record still
had many secrets to
relinquish he proposed that the Cambrian
explosion was merely an artifact of an
incomplete
record it was as if we had our hands on
volume two of the Encyclopedia of animal
life but volume one was still
languishing somewhere in the stacks yet
to be
discovered then around the turn of the
20th century the American paleontologist
Charles do little Walcott expanded on
Lyle's
hunch
suggesting that there must be missing
links out there that showed the gradual
evolution of animal life prior to the
Cambrian
explosion he was so confident of this
assertion that he did what none before
him had done and gave a name the lealan
period to the missing period of time in
which this supposed animal Evolution
took
place prior to the precise isotopic d of
rocks such a period could indeed be
sandwiched between the known eras whose
relative ages are only known by their
relationship to one
another wot proposed that the animal
missing links were confined to an as yet
undiscovered lealan
ocean which when uncovered would sit
between the earliest Cambrian and the
latest protozoic
strata in that golden age of
paleontological Discovery it was
certainly a
possibility and one to inspire
exploration for decades to
come and in 1905 the British geologist
William Solas offered yet another
explanation for the Cambrian
explosion justifying why Precambrian
animal ancestors might have thus far
proved tricky to find
at that time the Cambrian fossil record
consisted almost exclusively of animals
in possession of
shells the trilobites brachiopods
sponges and echinoderms whose
mineralized remains are less ravaged by
Decay and which can more easily survive
the transformation from sedimentary
detritus to coherent
[Music]
Rock could it be he pondered the that
this was the real Innovation that caused
the Cambrian
explosion that the beginning of the
Cambrian wasn't the moment that all
animals appeared but rather when they
evolved the ability to make shells and
withstand the fossilization
process and this was a proposition that
at least had some evidence to support
[Music]
it Solace noted that the further back
one goes through the camber
the smaller thinner and more delicate
the shells of those primitive animals
become it seemed logical that prior to
that explosive moment there were animal
ancestors but they were soft bodied
juicy and quickly devoured before they
had any hope of being
preserved however the last 100 years of
P ological Discovery hasn't quite
unfolded the way these Scholars
predicted new Fossil Beds have been
discovered all over the world but the
Bounty they contain has served only to
compound the Cambrian conundrum not
resolve
[Music]
it Walcott himself was complicit in
discovering a new fossil assemblage high
in the Canadian Rockies of British
Columbia dating to the middle Cambrian
the Burgess Shale contains intricate
flattened fossils of the most bizarre
animal
fossils preserved as thin organic and
phosphatic films between layers of gray
slate these fossils are almost
exclusively soft bodied without a shell
in
sight and their Discovery serve to
dismantle solace's argument that fleshy
animals would be missing from the fossil
record other such examples of
exceptional preservation have since been
found throughout the latest protozoic
and earliest Cambrian
periods in China the MEO Chan Shan
shales date from the early Cambrian
around 515 million years
ago and contains similarly flattened
fossils of soft-bodied
animals this time preserved by fine clay
[Music]
minerals the so-called Chang Jang biota
offers a valuable window into some of
the earliest Cambrian animal
ecologies including a diversity of CH
dates the group that would eventually
give rise to
us
from the 1950s strange impressions in
sandstones were uncovered in England and
in
Australia and soon became recognized as
an entirely new fossil
assemblage dating to that critical time
just before the Cambrian
explosion but these edaron fossils who
now boast representatives from Russia
Canada Namibia and elsewhere looked
nothing like the animals that we know
today and be none of the distinctive
characteristics that would Ally them
with one of the two dozen filer that
appeared
[Music]
later they may have been life's first
experiment with
multicellularity but they were nothing
like the missing links that Charles
Walcott imagined
in fact the modern paleontological
inventory contains more than the late
19th century scientists could have ever
hoped for with countless examples of
exceptional
preservation unprecedented resolution of
stratagraph
relationships and precise isotopic
dating of rocks half a billion years old
geob biologists have been able to chart
the progress of early animal evolution
with pinpoint
Precision they have seen how the
earliest experiments in body plans
resolved into a common theme of
bilateral
symmetry something still seen today in
everything from worms and mollusks to
us they have shown how the entire
Cambrian ecology was transformed by the
invent ition of burrowing and
swimming as revealed by the traces left
behind by wriggling and scurrying
creatures that disturb the sediment in
brand new
ways and they have finally done what
those geoscientists tried to do in
Prague in
1968 and have definitively established
the boundry between the Precambrian and
the
Cambrian and mark the moment that the
Cambrian itself
began the Advent of vertical
burrowing this wealth of information
helps to unpack the events of the
Cambrian explosion Moment by
moment we now see how animals
Diversified and radiated in a stepwise
fashion throughout the early
Cambrian we even see groups become com
extinct before the explosion itself is
over it is as if we are peering into the
rolling clouds of a physical blast
seeing the everchanging blooms of
material expand and diverse tracking the
paths of shrapnel through the
fog in a period that is biologically
long and yet geologically short the
diversity of animal life blossoms as the
new the invented forms come to dominate
the
[Music]
oceans the fossil record is certainly
not
lacking but for all of this incredible
resolution the picture still freezes
before the moment of
ignition we see the expanding blast and
the furoic aftermath but we still still
cannot clearly see the beginning or most
critically the
[Music]
cause the explosion of animal life may
not be
instantaneous but it appears to be real
after
all and so we are left still needing to
identify the agent of Miraculous
Creation
was there some extrinsic Factor some new
configuration of Earth ocean and
atmosphere that primed the world for
revolution or was it something unseen
within the organisms
themselves an intrinsic switch that
opened the door to
unprecedented
innovation
tectonic plates
move deep in the earth vast unseen
forces collude to jostle the fractured
slabs of solid rock that make up the
fractured armor of our
planet and ancient continents are torn
aunder and unceremoniously piled
together again folding and crumpling
over on themselves in tortured
heaps and as mountains rise their Roots
plunge deeper into the upper mantle
bearing not just the crushing force of
inexorable
Collision but also the weight of some 70
kilm of towering Rock and the intense
heat of the semi-solid mantle that
swirls in slow motion around their
inverted craggy
[Music]
Bluffs it is a place of extremes where
Solid Rock reaches the highest
temperatures and pressures to be found
in the Earth's
crust and it is a place where time
capsules are
created Because deep in these tight
Mountain forges silicon oxygen and the
metal zirconium are fused together into
intricate laes to shape elegant pale
yellow faceted crystals of
[Music]
ziron each strike of the metamorphic
Hammer each convulsion of the planetary
pileup leaves a trace in these growing
crystals like tree rings that tell Tales
of Environmental will boom and
[Music]
bust in time the collisions will cease
and the mountains will begin to erode
away with their upper layers Stripped
Away the hearts and roots of the range
Will Rise boyed by the dense mantle
below eventually those torture forged
zeror crystals will be exposed to the
air as
well where they will be Prim made from
the rocks that embrace them by wind
water and
ice to join Detroit Us in the Sandy
Mountain
Streams which carries the mountain
itself away grain by
[Music]
grain much of that mountain sand won't
even survive the journey to the
Sea before chemical alteration and
physical abrasion sees it transformed or
obliterated but the zircons
persist they are tough and utterly
unreactive so they survive transport
deposition even lithification that traps
them inside new sedimentary
rocks the these minerals retain their
faceted
structure their treel likee Rings
through hundreds of millions of years of
geological formation and
[Music]
destruction and they persist to this
day in sediments or in sedimentary rocks
geologists find these precious mineral
time capsules dating back to the very
beginning of our planet planet's
history with the radioactive isotopes
that can date them and the ringed zones
that tell of their
formation they are tiny crystalline
Windows into immense crustal
upheaval there are zircons around today
that span almost the whole of Earth's
history
but there is an unexpected absence of
specimens that are aged around half a
billion years
old this Bountiful collection of time
capsules from around the end of the
protozoic point to a period of
unprecedented Mountain
formation a time when Mountain routs
grew deeper and wider than ever
before and were matched on the surface
by super mountains
the sheer scale of which has never been
seen on Earth
before or
since is it made chance that this
extraordinary period of tectonic turmoil
coincided with the greatest evolutionary
leap our planet has ever
seen or could these end protozoic super
mountains be somehow
linked to the events of the Cambrian EXP
[Music]
explosion it isn't unreasonable to
consider environmental transformation as
a principal driver for
evolution after all it is often new
environmental pressures or opportunities
that Force the hand of natural
selection leading to Innovation that
helps organisms adapt and thrive in
their
habitats indeed the highresolution
fossil record we now have from the
earliest Cambrian strata show that The
evolutionary advancements of the
so-called explosion didn't happen
everywhere all at
once in some places Evolution raced on
ahead while in others it's stalled biing
its time before the new Innovations
arose
[Music]
and that may simply be a consequence of
the environments that
prevailed in modern and ancient oceans
warm shallow Waters such as those found
around the fringes of Continental
shelves are linked to biological
success larger body sizes greater
diversity Advanced ecological
interactions and more intricate
biomineral generalization are all
characteristic of these Azure
[Music]
Waters the Glorious atol communities of
the Red Sea the Barrier Reef and the
Caribbean keys are all Testament to the
Bounty of these shallow sunlit
paradises so it has been suggested that
the incursion of seawater onto the early
Cambrian Continental shelves perhaps as
a result of global sea level rise or the
reshuffling of continents was enough to
create Edens all over the
[Music]
world allowing early animals to thrive
innovate and
[Music]
evolve indeed it helps to explain the
staggered arrival of new animal forms at
different locations around the
globe as different shelves were flooded
in
sequence but it does little to explain
the origin of the animal groups in the
first
[Music]
place the sea has invaded Continental
shelves many times throughout Earth's
history and while it may have created
more Clement condition in which life can
Thrive it does not typically lead to a
radiation or diversification of that
life in an of
itself no while the newly made animals
may have found a comfortable home in the
lagoons of the early Cambrian it was
probably not those lagoons alone that
created
them instead it was likely another
unseen feature of the shallow sunlit
Paradise that drove the biological
Innovation at the beginning of the
Cambrian because Waters shallow enough
to be kissed by the sun are also shallow
enough to exchange oxygen with the
air it is oxygen in the
water rather than mere warmth or calm
conditions that has the power to
supercharge
[Music]
life it is oxygen which in modern and
ancient Waters leads to bigger animals
more elaborate shells higher mobility
and more
predation it is oxygen that opens the
door to biological
Innovation and it is oxygen which up
until this pivotal moment has been
lacking in the late protozoic
ocean the gas which we have come to
consider essential to all life on
Earth has had something of a checked
history on our
planet completely lacking from the
oceans and atmosphere for the first 2
billion years its debut around 2.4
billion years ago thanks to the newly
invented photosynthesis was met with
catastrophe in the living
world life forms that had no need to
evolve resistance to the reactive gas
now found themselves asphyxiated and
smothered by this new invisible
toxin the very photosynthesizing
organisms that produced it as a
byproduct was slaughtered on mass by
their own
waste
with oxygen in the shallow water and
atmosphere the entire Earth
transformed shattering warming
greenhouse gases and plunging the earth
into a frigid
glaciation through which much of life
was unable to
weather by the time the planet had
emerged from this big freeze microbial
life had learned to protect itself from
the damaging
gas
allowing photosynthesis to continue
among cyanobacteria and eukaryotic
algae and allowing oxygen levels to
stabilize alongside protozoic
life but those levels were a far cry
from the oxygen we enjoy
today with only microscopic contributors
to the gas's
reservoir concentrations reach little
more than 10% of M
levels and many scientists believe that
this alone was enough to impede the
development of any larger more complex
or more Mobile
Life but something changed in the early
Cambrian tracing the record of oxygen
through time is not always
straightforward simply because the gas
is so reactive and often doesn't stay
where it's put whether that be in water
sediment or
air so researchers must instead search
for Clues from other
elements like carbon and sulfur whose
cycling through the Earth is
fundamentally different when oxygen is
or isn't
present and sulfur and carbon Isotopes
trapped in ancient rocks Whisper of
intriguing changes in oxygenation around
the end of the
protozoic the newest data points to more
widespread oxygen in the
atmosphere as well as discernable pulses
in oxygen in the ocean linked intimately
in time to the radiations of life during
the Cambrian
[Music]
explosion this is the very relationship
that's seen in more modern
ecosystems echoed down Through the
Ages with more oxygen around cellular
metabolisms have more fuel for their
furnaces more opportunity to experiment
with bigger growth greater complexity
and more extravagant
Mobility and so many scientists are
happy to ascribe the diversification of
animal life to more freely available
oxygen at the beginning of the
Cambrian but the question remains what
caused that increase in oxygen in the
first
[Music]
place and that is where the zircons the
mineral time capsules that are uniquely
able to withstand the trials of
Millennia have something to tell
[Music]
us their abundance at that pivotal time
tells of a rare and extreme tectonic
event that saw the creation of super
mountains that span the early Cambrian
[Music]
landmass larger scale plate tectonic
reconstructions reveal that from around
800 million years ago go right up until
the beginning of the
Cambrian the continents of the world
were assembling into a single immense
supercontinent
[Music]
gondwana the vast tectonic forces that
drove that Continental pile up were
responsible for raising the so-called
trans gondwanan super mountains
[Music]
reaching more than 5 kilm high 1,000
kilm wide and 8,000 km
long this mountain range stretched some
twice the length of the United
States 20% of the circumference of the
globe and it had a profound effect on
the
planet
because the Assembly of gondwana also
saw the creation of huge volcanic chains
pumping out vast quantities of carbon
dioxide into the
atmosphere extra greenhouse gas LED
temperatures to rise accelerating the
process of weathering at the very same
time that plate tectonics was providing
ever more raw material that could be
well
Ed over millions of years wind water and
ice ground the trans gondwanan super
Mountain down to Mere sand and
mud enough to cover the entire United
States more than 10 kilm
[Music]
Deep but all that detritus didn't stay
on
land it was washed into the oceans as a
fertilizing plume for waiting
phytoplankton to Feast
upon with such a banquet green algae and
cyanobacteria
bloomed creating a significant uptake in
photosynthesis
worldwide releasing oxygen into the
shallow ocean and
[Music]
atmosphere that oxygen which came about
ultimately because of motions inside the
earth then became the driving force
behind a burst in animal
Evolution it is certainly a neat
explanation and one that is sure to
appeal to every kind of
geoscientist since it involves every
part of the Earth's system from Hard
Rock to climate to the living components
of our
world
while the trans gondan and super
Mountain may have been impressive in its
extent it probably wasn't the first or
last of its
kind continents have piled together into
massive supercontinents several other
times throughout Earth's
history with Associated volcanism and
mountain building
events but tectonic upheaval isn't
always met with dramatic run rises in
oxygen
levels all with unprecedented leaps in
evolution likewise oxygen levels have
had stepwise increases and fluctuations
throughout geological time but they
haven't always been linked to tectonic
turmoil or to animal
radiation of course there is yet another
possibility
[Music]
one which requires us to challenge the
seemingly obvious and question our base
assumptions there is no denying that the
unmatched radiation of animal life at
the beginning of the Cambrian coincided
with a rise in atmospheric and oceanic
oxygen
levels but that does not intrinsically
imply that the oxygen caused that burst
in
evolution
merely that the two are coincident in
time in fact it could be that the
relationship is turned on its
head and the bursting forth of life
itself caus the rise in oxygen
levels animals don't have the same
capabilities for producing oxygen as
their photosynthetic plant and algal
cousins but they do still still have
ways to modify their
[Music]
environment recalling that the first
moments of the Cambrian explosion were
marked by the Advent of vertical
burrowing the appearance of animals also
saw an unprecedented disturbance of seaf
FL sediments that had up to this point
been little more than a passive chemical
Reservoir as newly mobile burrowing
animals dig down through ocean
sediments they are the ones who release
the nutrients trapped
within offering fuel for the
photosynthetic life that lingers at the
sidelines allowing them to share in the
success and produce more oxygenic waste
in the
[Music]
process in this Theory it must be animal
life that came first and the oxygen rise
second we may not ever definitively be
able to know from the chemical Whispers
contained within the Rocks whether it
was the geologically mediated rise in
oxygen that spurred on animal
Evolution or the modification of
geological environments by animals that
caused the rise in oxygen levels in the
early
Cambrian
perhaps both mechanisms were in play
reinforcing one another to accelerate
diversification and animal radiation
across the
world and yet the environment of the
early Cambrian alone cannot fully
explain the beginning of the Cambrian
[Music]
explosion the reason why animals
appeared in such numbers and Variety in
the first
place it is unlikely that environmental
oxygen was enough to light such a fire
under the backside of evolution without
something else at
[Music]
play some mechanism that loaded the
barrel and guided the hand of natural
selection to light the fuse on the
Cambrian
explosion
[Music]
it was 1950 When Alan Turing flushed
with optimism about the capabilities of
the new mathematical computer first
contemplated a future in which such
computers could think for
themselves in his mind he saw them
solving problems and making decisions
just as a human
would he foresaw a time when the
products of computers would be all but
indistinguishable from those of living
breathing
humans giving his name to the test that
would aim to make that
distinction unfortunately the room
filling computers of the time were a
long way from being able to realize two
in's heady
[Music]
imaginings little more than extremely
expensive bulky
calculators most were incapable of
storing commands with which to make
those
decisions let alone conduct the natural
language conversation that the Turing
test was based
[Music]
upon
the following decades saw vast
improvements in computer hardware and
software processors became smaller
operations became faster and memory
capabilities became vastly
[Music]
greater neural networks which connected
commands into a Cascade similar to our
own biological brains promised to
advance the art of artificial decision
making
soon the idea of artificial intelligence
didn't seem so far
away inspiring works of fiction that
foretold the downfall of humanity at the
hands of our digital
Masters in 1970 computer scientist
Marvin Minsky predicted the computers
could attain a general intelligence
equal to that of a human in 3 to 8
years but among these optimistic
predictions and the everpresent fear of
an imminent sentient robot
Revolution the reality never quite
managed to live up to the AI
promise it became clear that such a
general intelligence that Minsky
imagined would require computational
power millions of times greater than
that what most processors could
must Alan Turing would most likely have
been disappointed with the jilted
Glitchy conversations that were the
result of even the most complex neural
network rumors of our imminent downfall
it seems were greatly
exaggerated and the dream of generally
intelligent computers faded along with
interest and funding for its
research but in the last decade while we
were all looking the other way
artificial intelligence has experienced
something of a surgeon
success in the era of big data in which
information about everything is
available and shared thanks to the
internet modern artificial intelligences
machine learning algorithms allow it to
learn from that
[Music]
data finally giving them the tools they
would need to make a decision just as a
human
would the 2020s so far have been defined
by advances in Ai and with computers
beating humans at chess and go they are
now taking on humans at their own
game chat GPT has suddenly explosively
achieved what Alan Turing always dreamed
a thinking computer would in producing a
wealth of AI generated content that is
all but indistinguishable from man-made
works the pace of AI development was
slow at times seemingly
non-existent but the incremental
developments that were made in the
shadows accumulated
gradually suddenly and without warning
or Fanfare an extraordinarily powerful
AI algorithm
existed and because of the nature of
computing
today it is
everywhere this was a revolution a
seemingly miraculous Act of digital
creation that mirrors the explosive
moment of animals arrival during the
Cambrian
[Music]
explosion just like AI there seemed to
be a whole lot of nothing going on until
suddenly and without warning fully
formed animals appeared and were
immediately
successful could it be that like their
digital counterparts animals
underwhelming pred processors were
slowly acing new innovations that
readied them for their moment in the
Limelight
540 million years
[Music]
ago it's very likely that the
developments that led to the Cambrian
explosion will always remain hidden to
[Music]
us much of the stuff that makes an
animal and animal such as their cell
structure and genetic makeup are
elements that do not really enter the
fossil record
even the highest Fidelity cellular of
fossils preserved in finely crystallined
Clays and phosphate fail to retain true
information about the chemical and
biological makeup of those
cells as such scientists are left
speculating based on what the fossil
record can tell
us and what we can discern from the
cells and genes of existing animals and
their close
relatives
one such speculation wild though it may
seem is that cancer one of the most
destructive phenomena in multicellular
organisms may have been key to their
appearance in the first
[Music]
place we've already seen how a rise in
atmospheric and oceanic oxygen coincided
with the rise of animal
life this makes sense on the scale of
ecos systems and entire
organisms since oxygen is the fuel for
our biological power plants an increase
in that fuel means an increase in output
on all
fronts from size to
Mobility but on a cellular level the
appearance of complex multicellular
animals alongside an oxygen rise is
counterintuitive stem cells which are
The Versatile so-called PL potent cells
from which all of our specialized
tissues develop behave in the opposite
way to how we might expect in the
presence of
oxygen when oxygen concentrations are
low stem cells replicate quickly
creating more cells more rapidly however
when oxygen levels are high the stem
cells mature and their replication slows
down in this way oxygen actually becomes
a hindrance to
multicellularity making it all the more
surprising that complex macroscopic
animals even could evolve during the
times of rising oxygen in the early
[Music]
Cambrian however there is one way in
which cells circumvent this shutting
down of stem cells and that's in the
formation of
tumors cancerous tumor arise from cells
with broken DNA that essentially fools
the Machinery of the cells into thinking
that oxygen is low even when it's
not under what it believes to be
immature low oxygen conditions the cells
replicate unchecked growing out of
control and creating the kinds of tumors
that can take over normal tissue and
spread beyond their origin in search of
more space to
expand
in a fully developed modern animal such
tumor development can be extremely
damaging to the highly tuned Bly
functions and is ultimately
fatal but in those burgeoning animal
ancestors first experimenting with
multicellular ways of life during the
late
protozoic this kink in the genes could
have given biology the nudge that it
needed to succeed despite the rise in
oxygen
with a cancer-like mutation of the
ancestral stem cells these key
components of a multicellular body could
have remained immature and plur
potent and kept on replicating out of
control even when elevated oxygen levels
would have otherwise shut them
down today Cancer kills but in the early
Cambrian it might have been the very
thing to give animals
[Music]
life but there are other breadcrumb
trails to be found within the unmutated
DNA of animals which can hint at their
development
too could these shed light on the
explosion of animal
[Music]
life there are certain specific genes
that are needed in the instructions for
making an
animal such as those which tell cells to
stay stuck
together those that instruct cells to
differentiate and perform certain
functions and those which coordinate the
intricate dance that is animal
immunity philogenetic trees of life that
reconstruct the relationships between
organisms and molecular clocks that
trace the gradual appearance of genes
over geological time reveal that some of
these animal specific genes actually
predate the appearance of animals in the
fossil
record however others appear for the
first time during the Cambrian explosion
alongside the animals that they
encoded and so genetic scientists today
are faced with much the same conundrum
as Darwin 150 years ago in trying to
trace the origins of animal genes
and explain how so many could appear so
suddenly ultimately the DNA inside our
cells is subject to the same
evolutionary pressures as the
characteristics that they program with
changes occurring naturally and natural
selection favoring those which work best
for the
organism so we might expect the animal
specific genes to have evolved gradually
over the latter part of the protozoic
[Music]
perhaps being derived from genes that
served their unicellular
ancestors but some scientists believe
that the genes themselves and their
animal manifestations as a result really
did spring up faster than normal natural
selection would
countenance some extraordinary genetic
event that kickstarted animal Evolution
from from a molecular
level some will claim that extraordinary
events require extraordinary
triggers and there's not much more
extraordinary than the viral panspermia
hypothesis which invokes an
extraterrestrial source for the genetic
novelty that kickstarted the Cambrian
explosion our planet is constantly being
bombarded by material from the Stars
relativistic particles that bounce off
our magnetosphere and create stunning
auroras microm meteorites that burn up
in the upper layers of the
atmosphere and according to some authors
intact genetic molecules capable of
transforming life on
Earth panspermia is one of the many
hypotheses put forward to explain the
origin of Life on our
planet through seeding of cosmic organic
molecules or even entire
extraterrestrial
microbes so viral panspermia as a
mechanism for the Cambrian explosion is
merely an extension of these
ideas if viral style DNA is circulating
freely through the cosmos then that
novel DNA May rain down on our planet
survive its descent
and infect the eukaryotic life in
Earth's
oceans with an injection of alien genes
life could Leap Forward at a rate unseen
at any other time in history and create
life forms the like of which had never
been seen
[Music]
before it is certainly an evocative idea
but unfortunately it it's rather
unlikely and somewhat difficult to
prove there is nothing in the animal
genome today that hints at a cosmic
origin and although simple organic
molecules have been detected inside
Interstellar gas clouds even our best
telescopes have failed to identify
anything that might be a genome altering
virus beyond our
planet but there is yet another
possibility for this leap in genomic
Evolution one that doesn't require alien
invasion in the animal genome today
homeobox genes help to shortcut the
instructions for building a body by
providing a kind of body plan
template they are a kind of higher tier
instruction that encodes large scale
anatomical features like a leg or an
entire body
segment and scientists first explored
the function of Haw genes in fruit flies
by making small changes to the DNA code
which caus the fly to grow a leg from
its head in place of an
antenna so some scientists speculate
that these homeobox genes could have
been very powerful during the
diversification of animals during the
early
Cambrian with an easily editable
template an animal wouldn't have to
gradually evolve all of the genes
required for growing a new leg or body
segment
they would need only acquire a mutation
that duplicated the entire
segment in this way animals could copy
and paste the appendages that they
already had to experiment with brand new
body
shapes with tweaks to the homeobox
template it's not hard to see how
animals could suddenly and spectacularly
diversify with the successful new body
plans living on to found the major
animal filer
indeed it's conceivable that it was the
evolution of homeobox genes in the first
place that provided the first Spark for
the Cambrian
[Music]
explosion however the origin of these
genetic sequences is not
clear and at least some of our homeo
book genes are also shared by plants and
fungi
like so much of this pivotal time of our
Evolution the chronology is
muddied and may never be fully
revealed our understanding of genetic
evolution is better than it ever was but
it still leaves a lot to be desired the
murky history of homeobox genes is only
a symptom of a deeper lack in
understanding about the molecular
machinations that underpin evolution
perhaps an extraordinary explanation is
needed for the surge in genetic
Evolution at the time of the Cambrian
explosion or perhaps this is a normal
State of Affairs during times of
ecological
upheaval in other words perhaps it was
the environmental pressures and
opportunity that accelerated the genomic
change rather than the genetic Evolution
leading the way
[Music]
but what changed in the ecology that
could have spurred such a dramatic
Revolution when considering the
excitement of the Cambrian explosion
it's easy to forget the other players on
the vast living
stage even while idar rise and fall and
the first animal filer take their
tentative steps on the muddy sea floor
the oceans and even the Nearshore land
surfaces are teeming with
life up until this point
photosynthesizing cyanobacteria and
eukaryotic algae have been the main
event for life on
Earth and it's possible that it's their
interactions that kickstarted the
emergence of
animals in what has become known as the
Slime Theory of the Cambrian explosion
researchers think that the outcome of
territorial battles between procaryotic
cyanobacteria and eukariotic green algae
was what opened the door for the
evolution of
[Music]
animals even after the first UK carots
evolved at some point during the
Mesozoic they were still vastly
outnumbered by the cyano
bacteria these procaryotes thve thanks
to their Simplicity packaging the
Machinery of photosynthesis into the
most basic possible
cell they do well for themselves but
cyanobacteria don't give much back to
the
ecosystem swallowing up nutrients and
only releasing them when they die
already buried in in tuming sediment
there is little left behind to support
any other
life but things change around the time
of the snowball glaciation at the end of
the
[Music]
protozoic here scientists find a surge
in molecular fossils that could have
only been produced by eukariotic
algae this patchy record tells of a time
when finally cyano bacteria's choke hold
on our oceans was
broken allowing photosynthesizing UK
carots to become dominant for the first
time to the Casual Observer the
difference may seem minor but the more
complex cell structure and Metabolism of
ukar offered a great deal more to the
rest of the
ecosystem now there were energy-rich
cells worth eating and nutrient stores
that could be effectively tapped
into for the first time there were food
chains and webs with something
substantial at their
basis eukaryotic productivity shifted
the pace of ecological
turnover and opened a door for more
energy hungry life to
thrive with more energy available to the
simple consumers of the late protozoic
oceans the community enters into a
runaway cycle of positive
feedback early animals could move more
than ever before exploring their
environment and learning to burrow down
into the sediment
[Music]
this first 4A into ecosystem engineering
transforms the two-dimensional protozoic
world into a three-dimensional Cambrian
one with all the additional opportunity
that a new dimension can
offer new niches open inside the
sediment and the water column and
organisms invent new ways of
living
zoa Plankton tiny living animals that
can float in the water and make the most
out of the alal produces there provide
links between the seaf Flor and the open
ocean and for the first time higher
organisms can evolve to Prey Upon these
lesser
animals with predators and prey comes an
arms race of defense and
attack leading to the appearance of
mineral armor and weaponry in the the
form of protective shells and hardened
mouth
[Music]
Parts eventually for the benefit of both
predators and prey eyes evolve as
[Music]
well from a simple change in the kind of
slime on the ocean's surface the mere
machinations of Nature and natural
selection are able to do the
rest
whether this ecological transformation
would have been enough to drive genetic
Revolution itself whether the genetic
blueprint was in place or whether there
were other factors either extrinsic or
intrinsic at Play It's hard to
know in reality it is very unlikely that
there was ever a single thing that
caused the Cambrian
explosion but rather an accumul ation of
factors that created a Cascade away from
an old microbial equilibrium and towards
a new multicellular
one big evolutionary events like these
need not require a big evolutionary
cause but merely an accumulation of
favorable conditions and a nudge in the
right direction at the right time to tip
the
balance
as with the dramatic explosion of
artificial intelligence in recent years
it begins with the Gathering of small
seemingly unremarkable
changes by themselves they aren't enough
to transform anything but they interest
ever closer to a Tipping
Point we may not know when or how the
breakthrough will happen
but one final Innovation is enough to
send the whole system over the
edge Shifting the Paradigm and creating
powerful
AI or creating a new kingdom of
life and ultimately changing the world
[Music]
forever the Cambrian explosion has only
ever happened on earth
once and so we have nothing to compare
it to no other points of
reference in this we are as ignorant of
the origins of animals as we are on the
origin of life
itself more than 150 years on from
Darwin's tortured contemplation of the
Cambrian
explosion we have more knowledge and
more hypotheses than he could have ever
dreamed but we are per perhaps still no
closer to knowing what one thing if any
one thing caused the sudden appearance
of animals on
Earth perhaps we never
[Music]
will you've been watching the entire
history of the earth don't forget to
like And subscribe and leave a comment
to tell us what you think thanks for
watching and we'll see you next next
[Music]
time